foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
from bench to bedside targeted Gene
editing this webinar is a part of the
fifth annual crispr virtual event
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
Millipore Sigma for more information
about Millipore Sigma please go to Sigma
aldrich.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find the live chat located at
the left of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the help desk button located at the
top of your screen within the navigation
bar or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract tab
from the menu at the left of your screen
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker
Dr Jennifer Bennett product manager at
Millipore Sigma
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the presenter tab from the
menu at the left of your screen
Dr Bennett you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction hi all
as she said I'm Jennifer Bennett and I'm
excited to tell you today about some of
the products that we have from bench to
bedside for targeted Gene editing
first the life science business of Merck
tgaa darmstadt Germany operates as
Millipore Sigma in the U.S and Canada
creating Therapeutics has been the
purview of large pharmaceutical
companies who have the budgets and the
production equipment for lengthy
Discovery pre-clinical and clinical
studies but as therapies have expanded
from small molecules to include novel
modalities like monoclonal antibodies
antibody drug conjugates and cell and
gene therapy uh
these have expanded out in the number of
companies that can work on them outside
of Pharma companies
in parallel the tools to innovate and
generate these therapies have expanded
becoming less expensive and more
accessible to researchers outside of the
pharmaceutical companies
however all researchers still need to
follow this high-level paradigm
first designing the experiment what are
you trying to solve and how do you plan
to do it evaluating and validating
choosing and validating your reagents
of course then creating the model that
you're going to use to both test and
build your therapy
evaluating or assessing your model by
whole model approaches including high
content Imaging genomics proteomics
metabolomics sometimes whole genome
sequencing and then re-uh doing this
multiple times during the discovery
process until this is optimized for
efficiency where then we move into the
translation phase where the model can be
tested for safety and efficacy in the
clinical trials
and we provide the tools and expert
technical support along this workflow
for every step through this and so we're
going to focus on an application
um targeted Gene editing that mirrors
this workflow today
so functional genomics sits at the Nexus
of Discovery using sequencing and
bioinformatic tools and applications in
understanding and treating disease
functional genomic tools help us to
evaluate the complex Junction between
genotype and phenotype and often help us
move from Theory to practical
application
functional genomics is a practical
science designed to bring together the
genomics and the phenotype closer
together and connect all of these As you
move towards your therapy and the
revolution of engineered models using
functional genomic approaches helps to
identify phenotypes isolate critical
factors determine biological mechanisms
assay outcomes assay new novel drugs and
modalities create experimental models in
both animals and cell lines and of
course in bioproduction
one area of functional genomics that has
grown of course in the genome
engineering over the years has evolved
toward more Precision in gene
modification and editing
new discoveries have been recognized and
created more efficient engineering tools
from chemicals that could create
advantageous gene mutation to store
Short stretches of RNA that could
silence genes to proteins that could be
engineered to both bind and cut specific
sequences of DNA these have continued to
evolve and the most recent of that is
crispr
crispr in fact began as the study of the
bacterial immune system but quickly
became a tool for creating model systems
and investigating diseases specifically
those that could not be investigated
from previous Gene editing systems
crispr screening technology opened new
Doors by providing versatile and simple
tools for high throughput investigations
and crispr has moved very quickly into
the clinic in just a decade five or six
in fact new therapies have been approved
by the FDA and over 50 clinical trials
are currently being conducted using
crispr gene editing reagents
but continue crispr continues to evolve
as new variants and new combinations are
invented to make that editing more
precise and safe for clinical use
so when people talk about the uses of
crispr and crispr-mediated Gene editing
they're usually talking about
nuclease-based creation of double strand
breaks when using nucleus-based crispr
Technologies we're really relying on
endogenous DNA repair mechanisms to
achieve the desired modification
the outcomes are achieved either through
non-homology and joining or homology
dependent repair or HDR
there are some tools and strategies that
can shift this balance a little bit
between these Pathways but it's not
really your choice which mechanism the
cell uses to repair the double strand
break and it predominantly uses
non-homology end joining often resulting
in loss of function mutations caused by
frame shifting insertions or deletion
one important difference between these
two Pathways is the error-free repair
and error per prone repair compared to
repairing off of the plasmid
homology dependent repair requires the
addition of a donor DNA template
for which to
um pull the the DNA off and integrate
into your target Gene of choice
of course when this repair pathway is
done endogenously in the cell it often
uses very similar sequences off of a
sister chromatid but in this case you'd
be introducing the DNA of interest that
you'd like to integrate integrate again
the default pathway tends toward
non-homology end joining and an HR is
mostly inefficient in many therapeutic
cell lines which makes this an area of
interest for increasing this to get new
mutations and substitutions
with crispr and with other genome
engineering tools you can achieve a wide
array of genetic modifications
so here we're looking at various places
on a gene where we can add in make
modifications using genome engineering
tools specifically with crispr as well
the predominance application most common
is usually a gene knockout and again
this uses that non-homology end joining
where creating a double strand break in
a Nexon results in insertions or
deletions of nucleotides
leading to a frame shift and incorrect
expression of that Gene generally a
knockout
but there are multiple other genomic
manipulations that can be achieved again
we talked about with HR integration so
for example using a reporter Gene
putting in a gfp construct behind your
Gene so that you can follow it in the
cell line this can be done with crispr
by putting in a donor gfp sequence to be
integrated at this site
the choice of which type of genetic
modification is critical to the success
of either the model that you're creating
or the therapeutic you're designing
so let's take a look at how some
researchers have used crispr in their
drug development pipeline
pde 10A is a phosphodiesterase that
inactivates both camp and cgmp and is
almost exclusively expressed by neurons
in the striatum a brain area often
targeted by antipsychotic drugs
researchers sought to inhibit pde 10A as
a novel therapeutic Avenue to discover
antipsychotics
they use the fluorescently tagged triple
knock-in u2os cell line
featuring endogenous tagging of three
Gene targets with different fluorescent
proteins
so we have Alpha tubulin tagged with gfp
in green
lamin B1 is tagged with bfp and beta
actin is tagged with RFP in red
a cell-based assay involving high
content Imaging was used by researchers
to identify a microtubule aggregation
phenotype that along with other
phenotypes was used as a measure of
toxicity
in a we have a DMSO control when added
to the cells that have been typed the
cortisol is a known it's a positive
control it's a drug known to create
microtubule aggregation and that's seen
here in those pictures
the researchers then tested two
different compounds compound 8148 and
compound zero five five eight and when
added to the cells they could tell the
difference in the phenotypes by the
tagged microtubulin
from these assays researchers were able
to eliminate compounds that would have
resulted in late stage failures costing
the company Millions
crispr is enhancing the early Discovery
workflows to provide more accurate
information before moving into those
pre-clinical stages
often Discovery work will include
functional genomic screening screening
at the whole genome pathway or family
level to identify crucial targets for
action and as we move down this funnel
the gene editing workflow decreases in
scale while increasing in specificity
and efficiency
while screening is an important tool for
which we offer several off-the-shelf and
custom reagents in this webinar we are
going to focus on editing of single
genes
so whether you're starting from
functional genomic screening hits that
have been validated or you know your
target of interest already and want to
just attack it without having to go
through screening
this next workflow can outline is a very
basic outline for how to perform these
crispr experiments
so again the first step is to determine
the type of modification you need to
make and in what model system and it
will have a large impact on the
downstream design
next we need to design the guide rnas
and choose a nucleus this step can
actually be quite overwhelming for new
users there's many different varieties
of nucleases many programs with which to
design guide rnas and many places to
Target those guide rnas
using our crispr design tool you can
actually put in the gene ID or a custom
sequence and get back guide RNA designs
that we've stratified by efficiency and
specificity for you we also have
pre-designed guide RNA sequences
targeting the majority of the mouth and
human genomes that have been validated
and they come from different libraries
like the Sanger Library
then it's a matter of choosing the
appropriate nucleus for example will you
be using a wild type cas9 our new cas9
plus a cas9 Nick Ace and which format
are you going to use
nucleases and guide rnas can be
expressed to be a plasmids mRNA
lentiviral constructs auras purified and
synthetic material each format has its
limitations and its advantages depending
on your end goal
at this stage it's important to clarify
your end goal to make sure you're using
the appropriate reagents do you intend
to use crispr reagents to modify a cell
line that can be used in cell therapies
or are you making a disease model line
that you can use to screen drug
compounds those are just two examples of
the many uses but knowing this up front
and selecting the right reagents will
save you time and trouble down the line
the next step is to introduce your
crispr complexes into your model system
of choice and evaluate the modification
efficiency
ideally you would choose several guide
RNA designs and introduce all of them in
parallel to choose the ones with the
highest efficiency
a t-71 digestion can give you a quick
evaluation to eliminate the guide rnas
that are not going to work
and further sequencing protein
expression phenotypic or morphological
assays can be done to confirm the guide
RNA is in fact creating the Target that
creating the modification that you want
additionally off target analysis can be
done at this stage
specificity for the Target sequence is a
key component of every crispr complex
and the more you know about possibly
deleterious mutations outside of your
target Gene the better suitage you'll be
when you go to translator model
depending on the efficiency seen in this
step you may need to optimize your
experiment and this can mean changing
the delivery method or trying new
conditions
designing new guide rnas in fact
choosing a different nuclease
and we've spoken to many researchers who
choose to move to higher quality or
higher performing reagents at this step
to increase the efficiency of their
chosen modification
using those high quality reagents will
make creating your model more successful
this may mean several iterations of this
going back all the way redesigning
choosing and going through again
it's an again it's an iterative process
and you continue to make it more
efficient as you move forward
once you've settled on the most
efficient reagents and have optimized
it's time to create your model
from there do you need to isolate or
select certain modified or edited cells
do you need to perform whole genome
sequencing
Lots can be done at this stage again to
look at the entirety of the model
and then once the model is created you
can be ready to move to the translation
stage where the focus is on scaling up
the therapeutic testing it in Vivo and
demonstrating the safety of the model
for this first part of the talk we're
going to focus on the first two areas of
this workflow designing and evaluating
efficiency and we're going to talk about
our Discovery portfolio that has many
different products for these two steps
while you can in fact use multiple
formats for your guide RNA and nucleus
we're going to focus on two that we
believe will be most efficient for
Downstream analysis
and that's the use of cast nucleases in
the purified protein format and
synthetic guide rnas
there are several advantages to the rnp
system so that combination of a purified
protein and a synthetic guide
first has very low cytotoxicity
introducing these into most cell lines
won't cause a toxic response a classic
example is using primary T cells
introducing exogenous DNA invokes a
cytotoxic response of the T Cell It's
effectively doing its job it's meant to
get rid of exogenous DNA so for crispr
that's not a great that's not great if
you want to modify primary T cells the
rnp complex reduces that possibility
rmps are also transient which is great
for therapeutic safety measures
introducing a plasmid or even an mRNA
that contains the crispr reagents those
reagents in the plasmid or mRNA form
live much longer inside the cell line
when they're introduced and therefore
the chances of them creating off-target
edits or modifications goes up with
proteins and the rmp complex most are
cleared within 48 to 72 hours following
introduction again reducing that off
target editing but causing the downside
that we need high efficiency reagents in
order to ensure High editing in that
short window
rnps then therefore have high on target
specificity because of their transients
they do work in non-dividing cell lines
they don't rely on the cell to express
like they do in the plasmid format so
you can put them in non-dividing primary
cells again a key model for therapeutic
development
and they don't leave any genomic
Footprints so they won't integrate into
your into the endogenous genome they're
there they're expressed and they get
degraded and move out
we have two different types of guide RNA
are available one is our two-part system
and the one part system the two-part
system involves a crrna which contains
that protospacer motif
about 20 nucleotides matching the target
sequence uh in the in your Gene of
Interest
and a standard Tracer RNA that would be
the same for every experiment
the sgrnas single guide RNA combines the
crrna and Tracer into one and there is
some research that suggests these are
more efficient than the two-part system
both the sgrna and the CRNA when made
synthetically can have stabilizing
modifications added on to them to reduce
the possibility of RNA degradation once
introduced into the cell
so let's take a look at the many
different options that we have for cas9
proteins in our Discovery portfolio
the first two that were published and
discovered of course are our wild type
cas9
and a new one that was that was created
a variant created shortly after the wild
type which is called the Nicos
so the wild type cast 9 generally has
very high Gene editing activity many
people use wild types still today
despite new variants
the nickis on the other hand instead of
making a double strand break like the
wild type it instead only Nicks one of
the two strands
therefore increasing its specificity the
downside with this is because it only
next one strand you actually need to
have both you need to have two sets of
guide rnas with Nick aces in order to
utilize the repair pathway and get the
indels or the integration that you want
however it is more specific than the
wild type another variant that we offer
in the ornp format that came shortly
after the wild type is What's called the
dead cas9 so this utilizes uh the Nick
Ace mutation and adds another one on top
this cas9 can bind to the DNA but it
doesn't cut it and this cas9 is the
basis for much of the crispr inhibition
and crispr activation work that's done
for regulating gene expression without
causing those heritable mutations
one of the ones that we want to go a
little bit in more in depth into today
is our cas9 plus variant
and this has both High editing activity
and on target activity and I'm going to
show you how we developed that
so first as I said the wild type cast9
has very high on target activity but as
we as many researchers and we discovered
through protein engineering of the Wild
Tech cas9
there is a balance between the editing
activity for the Target Gene and editing
activity for off targets or what we what
we call specificity
such that if you try to make the cas9
um or I'm sorry such that this wild type
cast9 because it has very high activity
on Target also tends to edit anything
that's slightly related to your On
Target Gene one two three base pair
mismatches often get edited as well so
the traditional wild type has very low
specificity
from that came the enhanced specificity
cas9 where researchers undertook protein
engineering efforts to increase the
specificity they found they could make
mutations within the cas9
protein that would reduce the off-target
editing and therefore increase
specificity the unfortunate side effect
is that it also reduced the On Target
activity so there's a balance here
between On Target and off Target and
when you make changes to one often the
other is affected
so what we did through multiple rounds
of protein engineering
is look for a cap9 that had both High On
Target activity and high specificity we
tested both in parallel through the
development of this variant and we came
up with a new variant a novel variant
that we call cas9 Plus
here on this graph here we have a look
at the On Target activity and we are
comparing wild type cast 9 in purple
the ESP cast 9 in blue a competitor cas9
in green and our cas9 plus here in
yellow
and when we look at three different
targets in HEK cells we actually see
that the cas9 plus maintains high levels
of Hot On Target activity as you see
here in blue what I just told you on the
previous slide that ESP cas9 had very
low activity across the three the three
sites
but what's great here with the On Target
activity is when we look off Target we
look at a close
um off-target sequence that was
differing by a single base pair we
actually see that the cas9 plus does not
edit there see here in purple how the
wild type will edit at this off Target
site at all three Gene targets but the
cas9 plus does not in fact the cas9 plus
has even lower off target editing than a
high fidelity competitor variant as well
so it combines the high specificity of
the ESP cas9 with the high on target
activity of the wild type to make the
most efficient cas9 Plus
Discovery work that's done again the the
guide RNA design and choice is a is a
crucial component of the crispr complex
and we offer standard single guide rnas
that can complex with the cas9 plus to
perform this editing here we're looking
at a graph of multiple Gene targets
looking at indel activity comparing the
standard sgrna so this is the one part
strna 2A came competitors standard
desalted sgrna and here when complexed
with cas9 plus and transfected into HCC
cells we see that the standard guiding
cas9 Plus have significantly have very
high activity across the board at all
sites and in fact are has significantly
more activity than a competitor guide
additionally there was no loss of
viability so one of the key
aspects of guide rnas because they are
synthesized
is that they may carry with them
artifacts from the synthesis reaction
that could cause toxicity in your model
of interest and of course as models get
more sensitive moving to primary cells
moving to animal models that toxicity
Associated toxicity with your crispr
components is a key variable that you
need to assess when choosing your
complex reagents
and we can show that our standard sgrnas
in fact offer very little toxicity and
in fact are better than a competitor uh
in this space
and therefore the cast 9 plus with
standard guide rnas are a high efficient
highly efficient editing complex for
most model systems
another tool that we have in our
Discovery bucket that can help in your
workflow is our cas9 gfp so this is
really great because it allows
visualization of Gene editing it's in
fact a fantastic tool for an
optimization of your delivery conditions
often the addition of a gfp to a protein
can have an effect on its function but
as you can see from the graph cas9 gfp
maintains very high activity just like
the wild-type cas9 variant on which it's
based and it does so better than
competitor versions that are attached to
gfp
the image on the left shows how cas9 gfp
can be used to measure delivery
efficiency by measuring the number of
gfp positive cells
we work with several researchers both
internal and as collaborators to use gfp
to evaluate different formulations of
complexes for delivery
in fact one of the key trends in the
crispr field is on nanoparticle
lipoprotein particles different delivery
methods for the crispr reagents for
therapeutic uses cas9 GSP is a great
tool when you're trying to optimize a
new delivery system or evaluate a new
delivery system for your therapeutic
because it allows both editing and
visualization in onecas9
once you have your reagents designed and
you've started your experiments
one constant need throughout the
workflow is to continually evaluate the
amount of editing that is occurring and
there are multiple methods that differ
in sensitivity
um the the time it takes to do them and
the cost to evaluate those editing
outcomes
three of them are outlined here the t-71
digestion kit which will go into a
little bit more in a moment it measures
indole size and efficiency estimates
we recommend that it can be used for
optimization of experimental design for
example in those early phases where
you're maybe designing five six seven
different guide RNA sequences to test
out this is again a great one to very
quickly give you an answer of which
guide RNA sequence is going to work and
which ones need to be trashed
it doesn't require specialized equipment
no bioinformatic analysis it has the
same day turnaround time and it's very
um cost efficient comes in a single kit
that you can do the entire experiment in
one day sign your sequencing and Next
Generation sequencing provide much more
detailed sequence information from the
target site of course these involve PCR
in up your target site of interest
and then usually sending them out
for reading on special instruments right
and then the the sequence reads will
come back so bioinformatic analysis is
in fact required of those to determine
how much of the sequence actually is
caught and how much is not it has a
longer turnaround time and it tends to
be more expensive however uh
they will be more sensitive both Sanger
and next-gen sequencing will give you
more sensitive estimates of how much
editing is done so again we recommend
maybe to start with the t71
um to weed out the guide rnas that don't
work and as you're optimizing further
down you want to confirm that with these
higher sensitive methods
a little bit further into the t71 assay
kit that we offer the first step here is
to isolate your genomic DNA from your
edited cells you will PCR amplify your
target region that has been edited
there's a denaturation step and then a
re-annealing so what happens is these
little pink spaces in here are
presumably the edit of interest and as
they are denatured they come apart into
single stranded pieces and when
re-annealed they don't always match up
perfectly and what you can get is
mismatched duplexes so on one strand
will be a mutation or an edit and on the
other strand might be a wild type that
didn't get edited and those are the
duplexes that are cleaved by the t7
endonuclease
then you run those out on a gel and what
you'll see is a pattern of in a negative
control you'll see no cutting because
everything was wild type and in
something that has been edited you
should see a banding pattern underneath
that should match up with where your
expected mutation was
here's an example a typical example of
the right here where we have our um our
transfection control that didn't have
editing reagent and then the edited
cells themselves you see there's still
some amount that was not edited and you
can use Imaging analysis to give a rough
estimate of the ratio of these bands to
get a rough efficiency number of how
well your guide rnas are doing again
this is a very fast low-cost method for
easy efficiency
so we've looked at these first two steps
and a number of the discovery products
that we have available to address them
now let's look at this back end of the
model
so as I mentioned remember when I
mentioned that the optimization often
requires higher quality and higher
performing reagents and that many
researchers switch to higher efficiency
reagents at this stage well we've
innovated a new portfolio of products to
address those needs and promote success
in your translational work
foreign ly launched translational grade
crispr reagents are engineered to meet
Superior manufacturing standards that
enable consistent and high quality
performance every time this new
portfolio is called Pure edict crispr
products
while our Discovery products are
appropriate for most of your early
Discovery and even some of your
pre-clinical study studies are pure edit
products in fact have the highest
performance higher quality standards and
quality documentation that make them
the appropriate choice and the best
choice as you're moving your Discovery
work through pre-clinical and into
clinical research phases
crippers Evolution has of course
included a rapid move into the clinic
where crispr reagents are being used to
generate cell in gene therapies to cure
a number of human health issues and
diseases
the attraction or one attraction of
crispr is that the change is permanent
so that change is embedded in the DNA of
the patient which prevents long-term
treatments or long-term drug use to
control the symptoms
additionally cures for rare genetic
diseases for which not much about the
biological mechanism now is known are
now relatively easy with crispr or at
least easier than before
and as part of the democratization of
creating new therapies a number of new
therapeutic companies have sprung up in
the wake of crispr who Focus
specifically on using crispr reagents
for Therapies
and the promise of crispr as a
therapeutic was a major contributing
reason why within 10 years of the first
publication the Nobel Prize was awarded
to Jennifer doudna and Emmanuel
charpentier
so let's dig a little bit deeper into
the pure edit portfolio and why it's
perfect for translational or therapeutic
research for Crispers
first as we discussed earlier the
advantages of rnps these advantages play
out for Therapeutics as well these are
all key points load cytotoxicity
transients which leads to higher safety
working in therapeutically relevant cell
model systems and of course no
integration into the genome leading to
no long-term Downstream effects all of
these are key points in why rnps are
quickly becoming the choice the format
of choice for therapeutic model
development
so if we look at the two different
pieces of this rnp complex
we have a pure edit cas9 protein in our
portfolio as well as a pure edit sgrna
our periodic cas9 protein has the
highest activity of any cas9 protein
that we offer it's also got the highest
specificity of any of the proteins that
we offer or that we've tested
it has 95 Purity and it's available off
the shelf
our periodic guide rnas again have
highest activity and Purity similar to
the protein we include stabilizing
modifications to prevent the degradation
these are made as custom products in
seven to ten business days and that's
the the quick delivery turnaround time
for that as well combining the periodic
guide RNA with the periodic gasoline
protein gives you the most efficient
cas9 complex
for your translational work
so let's take a little bit more look at
the data associated with this
so first to look at the On Target
activity here we're looking at periodic
cas9 in red a competitor High Fidelity
two competitor High Fidelity cast lines
in yellow and blue and you see here
um
at two different Gene sites in two
different cell lines the periodic cas9
is significantly higher On Target
activity than two other High Fidelity
variants
additionally when we compare the On
Target activity to the off Target
activity and plot that as a ratio you
see that the pure edit has the highest
ratio High ratio in this case is good it
means there's a lot of On Target
activity with very little off-target
activity that ratio is three uh six-fold
six-fold higher than the nearest
competitor this is incredibly important
for Therapeutics because you do not want
to have any off Target affects any
deleterious mutations as part of your
therapeutic that's a key safety
parameter that's going to become more
important than more strict as it's
moving forward with crispr into the
clinic
so when we dive into that specificity a
little bit more what we did here is
here on the left the the letters are
representing nucleotides in the
protospace OR motif
and in red are the nucleotides that we
changed
and so off-target effects of course it
means that that sequence that 20 base
sorry 20 nucleotide sequence
is very similar to the 20 nucleotide
sequence that you're trying to change
sometimes they only differ by a single
base pair sometimes as many as two three
four base pairs as you increase the
number of nucleotides difference between
your On Target and a different sequence
the spec or the chances the likelihood
of editing at that off Target site go
down with only a single base pair
difference there's a very high
probability that this sequence would be
edited in to the same extent that the
original Target sequence was
so we made Single base pair mutations
across the length of the protospace or
Matisse to look at how single base
single nucleotide mismatches affected
the specificity of the periodic castline
and you can see here in yellow is the
periodic cas9 and in purple is a high
fidelity competitor
resoundingly and across the board at two
different sites and at every base pair
we've tested the periodic cas9 has
significantly lower activity in most
places even in some places even when
it's only differing by a single base
pair there's almost the activity is
almost non-existent again this is a very
important parameter for Therapeutics and
so minimizing the chances that it would
interact with any off-target site is key
for moving things forward as a therapy
so not just the cast 9 is important for
this very specific and highly efficient
complex but also the periodic guides are
important so our Pure edit single guide
rnas are purified by hplc which gets rid
of and actively selects out any small
nucleotides sequences that could be left
over as well as other Trace Amounts in
in the
final product here what we've done is
compare our peer edit and our standard
guides across two different cell lines
actually three different signs HEK T
cells and a mouse cell line at a number
of different targets and you can see at
every Target site the pure edit guide
rnas have a little bit have more
activity than the standard guides
again suggesting that if high quality
High editing and specificity is key to
your work the Purity guide RNA is going
to be the way to go complex with our
Pure edit cas9 protein
so what we have here are two different
tiers of portfolios with products to fit
in every application our Discovery
portfolio and our peer edit portfolio
our Discovery portfolio is going to
focus on versatility ease of use pricing
and delivery time of course and it
contains many of the cas9 proteins that
we've talked about wild type cas9 plus
our castling gfp and of course our
standard guide rnas our Pure edit
portfolio is focusing on high
performance highest quality standards
quality documentation and is driven for
therapeutic research and these there are
two products in this portfolio as of now
peer edit guides and periodic cas9 it's
important to note that
um
you don't only have to use pure edit
products at the very late stages of your
your workflow
earlier you bring in the high efficiency
products the faster your timeline will
go
as I mentioned as part of that workflow
often multiple rounds of optimization
have to be done to get to the final
complex before you create your model
pure edit guides in cas9 can cut down on
that amount of optimization by giving
you the highest efficiency early on in
the process and reduce your overall time
to the clinic or to your your
pre-clinical studies
so we're constantly adding and always
working on adding new and Innovative rnp
products in both of these tiers to
address our the evolving needs of
researchers at various stages in gene
editing and I'm going to highlight one
of those ongoing initiatives for you
next
so one of the Next Generation genome
engineering tools that we're working on
is what we call crispr Chrome and this
involves a cas9 variant that is fused to
chromatin remodeling peptides
when we look compare three different
variants of fusions compared to the wild
type castmine we look at indel rates
and first here you see in Gray is the
wild type SP cas9 that has a very low
number of indels so this could be a gene
these are Gene targets that are
generally hard to edit uh multiple
rounds of Gene editing have shown us
that there are some Gene targets that
are just inherently more difficult to
edit than others for various reasons one
reason could be that the chromosome
architecture chromatin architecture
around them prevents accessibility to
the crispr complexes and so here you see
all of these four percent four percent
3.8 and 2.2 these Gene targets are very
difficult to edit and basically making
any therapeutic that would Target these
or other targets that are difficult like
them virtually impossible how do you how
do you get to a therapeutic if you only
get two percent editing
what we see here is that by fusing on
these chromatin remodeling peptides we
actually increase the indel activity
sometimes as much as five to six fold
across the board for all of them having
25 of cells being edited is much more
workable cell number than only four
percent and this makes the therapeutic
possible at this point
additionally we've looked at how these
variants compare
to the wild type cas9 when we're trying
to integrate a piece of DNA so we have
very low integration here six and a half
percent with the wild type but these
variants show increased as much as five
to almost six-fold here across all of
them again taking that efficiency higher
to allow this therapeutic strategy to be
successful where it would not have been
in the first place
and this is just one example of new
technology and Innovations for our rmps
that we're working on
so what's next for crispr and crispr
Therapeutics so to date many of the
Therapeutics and and the kind of the
headlines that I showed you have largely
focused on on easier targets the the low
hanging fruit if you will but there's a
number of different areas where
Therapeutics are moving in kind of that
next Generation uh genome engineering
it's including inserting DNA to repair a
place to harmful DNA sequences
Multiplex editing so multiple genes
being edited at one time you can imagine
that this increases deficiency while
decreasing safety concerns if you can if
you can edit two to three genes at once
you don't have to go back and do them
sequentially a lot less time for
off-target edits to occur so uh base
editing and then and Prime editing are
two new forms of what are would have
been termed Precision editing where
they're using crispr components to
directly change bases without making
double strand breaks in the base editing
you can directly change single DNA bases
and in Prime editing you can change both
single bases and longer stretches of DNA
the advantage here is that without the
double strand breaks there's less impact
to the remainder of the genome it
doesn't create breaks everywhere else in
the genome and have that Golf target so
again safer and more precise
and of course then crispr inhibition and
crispr activation the ability to turn
genes on and off without making breaks
at all is a key area of therapeutic
research as well
so what do we need what does crispr need
to be successful in Translation what do
we need to continue to work on to get it
to this stage
first better specificity without
decreasing efficiency and I showed you
one variant that we have well two
variants the cast name plus and the
periodic cas9 in which we have increased
specificity without without decreasing
that efficiency variants that have this
are going to be key candidates to move
forward
more precise editing
editing single nucleotides
inefficient Precision editing can limit
the field to therapies where Gene
functions need to be eliminated or where
corrected cells gain a competitive
advantage over the unrepaired cells
additionally improved access to Target
sites so right now
um
we are limited to targets that have Pam
proximal regions as well as to sites
that can be efficiently edited so
inclusion of variance to the nucleases
that expand our accessibility to the
rest of the genome virtually making it
able for a researcher to edit anywhere
that they want
without limitation will be key at moving
forward and finally delivery delivery is
another key factor here whether the
crispr reagents are being used to modify
a cell line and the cell line becomes
the therapeutic introduced into the
patient or the crispr reagents
themselves are the therapeutic
introduced into the patient the delivery
of that can have a huge impact on the
efficiency of it as a therapeutic but
also on the safety of it and so
continuing to innovate in new methods of
delivering new safer
methods of delivery is going to be key
to continue to pushing crispr forward
so as I've shown you throughout this
webinar we provide a number of solutions
that can cover the end-to-end workflows
for bench to bedside using gene editing
thank you for your attention to this and
I will take any questions
thank you Dr Bennett for your time today
and your important research before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today I'd also like to thank
our sponsors Millport Sigma for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until November 2nd 2024. lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye